an attack on democracy an attack on
freedom of expression and an attack on
european sovereignty that is how
european leaders
have been describing state organized
hijacking of a ryanair flight between
two eu member countries after belarusian
authorities forced the aircraft to land
in minsk
activist and journalist roman protasovic
was bundled away
amid fears for his life so how should
the eu respond
and what is vladimir putin's role in
this apparently brazen
piracy on to the point we ask lukashenko
orders kidnapping
that is putin pulling the strings
[Music]
well thanks very much indeed for joining
us here on to the point and my
guests here in the studio are olga
dorindova
political scientist from belarus her
opinion is that belarusians should not
be punished with sanctions
and locked inside belarus without air
connection
to europe also with us is daria
sukharchuk
editor with russian east west tv
in berlin she thinks putin is still
pulling the strings of lukashenko
if we want any kind of democratic change
in belarus we have to talk
to putin and a warm welcome to alexandra
von nerman dw's brussels bureau chief
she says sanctions against belarus will
be useless
if the eu doesn't formulate a strategy
that takes the role
of russia into account as well
[Music]
yeah thank you very much indeed for
great input there to begin with and i'd
like to go to olga first and just ask
you olga is it fair to say that for
anybody who
wants to see peace and democracy in
belarus in the near
future this has been a how should i put
a disturbing few days
well definitely for me was i would say
more shocking it's disturbing i mean
we know that belarus is a long-lasting
autocracy
and the whole thing is that we have been
observing in belarus since august
2020 these things
are shocking themselves but
what happened on the weekend is just i
mean i like the fantasy
to imagine uh to be able to imagine
something like that so it's it's a
really
uh i think it was a very emotional
action
emotional decision and well
when we think about the consequences of
the political the economic consequences
of the step
it's it's really not adequate for me so
it's i was really surprised i was
shocked yeah and
am i right in saying that what we have
seen in effect is a warning to
journalists a direct
and very and very dark warning to
journalists the
uh that critics of the regime are in
danger
i would say really not only journalists
but everybody who is now who thought to
be
safe abroad like the whole oppositional
leaders and people working with them and
people also represented here in germany
like belarus and diaspora for example
activists who speak up for belarus of
course they're afraid also
for their lives now because they did not
feel themselves
safe also within the european union
which was different before
before this story okay let's go to
alexandra von neumann in
in brussels you have alexander for many
years followed developments in belarus
in ukraine
and in in moscow very very closely so
what do you make of this
apparent state-sponsored hijacking that
we have witnessed
well i think that it was certainly an
unprecedented incident
and i think that it's going to cha
to change the approach of the european
union
and we saw it the reactions european
leaders who were
shocked and outraged and
they were describing the incident as a
state-sponsored
terrorism piracy but they were also very
concerned because
as they put it the lives of
eu citizens were at risk we talking here
about hijacking about
a diversion of a plane that was on its
way from
one european european capital to the
other
so i think this is something that the
european union now
um has to deal with and and it's an
incident that
is probably going uh to put a lot of
pressure
on brussels to to do more i'll go what
do you say to that that reaction in
brussels outrage
fury is it going to ch the suggestion
that it is perhaps a game changer is it
going to be a game changer
well we've already seen that it has at
least begun to be a game changer i mean
the reaction was
quite fast it was also surprisingly fast
for me
uh fast hard and quite emotional and we
can understand it
and we just heard one of the reasons for
that which is actually what is different
now
um when we compare the sedation before
the week and
after it's not
only about democracy in human rights
outside of the
anymore right so it's about also the
security of the european citizens and i
think it was
one of the re one of the main reasons
why the decision was made that fast
within just
a few hours this hard decision that mrs
t hanovska was
kind of claiming for half a year or
asking the eu
for for for half a year also heart
sanctions if they really come this
broad sector economic sanctions we've
been talking about for over half a year
already and now
this rhino story happens and they're
suddenly up
on the agenda so it's really a different
level of
of danger for the european union it's
not only
i say only of course it's important
democracy and human rights but it's
outside of the eu and when we have
citizens within the eu that
are put and um are put under danger by
the
belarusian authorities it's another
level of
also decisions and of political
involvement
and uh alexander i'd just like to come
back to you and just uh what
what if this if this is a game changer
if there has been a tectonic shift in
the approach towards
belarus what how is that likely to
manifest itself
in the weeks and months that lie ahead
well first of all what was just said is
right that
the decision was made very very quickly
and it is very surprising we just
have to keep in mind that we had two uh
big crisis
and and the attempts by the european
union to issue a joint statement one of
those
was the israel gaza crisis and and then
china's crackdown on opposition in hong
kong and in those very important foreign
policy measures
foreign policy matters rather the
european union
was not able to find a common position
to issue a common statement because one
member state
blocked those decisions and now here
within
a few hours you have a strong
response you have concrete measures
that were agreed on like this this ban
of landings by the state belarusian
state-owned
carrier belavia for example than the
announcement of
sanctions and we are apparently talking
here not only about
targeted sanctions against individuals
or
companies but we are apparently also
talking about sanctions against whole
industry sectors so it really appears
that the european union at least
at the moment is united and determined
to punish
lukashenko and his regime and also to
make
clear that they are not going to
tolerate such incidents uh
in the future um let's bring in daria
daria it's a
the the kremlin denies involvement in
sunday's operation
uh but a lot of experts say that
president putin would have known about
the hijacking incidents
what's your take on that very important
question did he know or did he not know
i think we're never going to know for
sure if he personally said yes
to this landing of a plane
or if he was somehow talking to
lukashenko in the days before and
they've agreed that
this is the way they're going to get
protest however
i think that it is not very important
for us in europe to know
whether putin was personally involved
with this particular ancient
incident in the minsk airport on may
23rd what is important is that putin is
the biggest supporter of lukashenko
he is giving him money russian border is
essentially the only open water that
still remains for belarus
there is a lot of interaction
between these two governments and putin
essentially is the one
pulling the strings of lukashenko
although lukashenko is well known for
acting on his own he's not exactly
completely controlled by putin that
would not be true of course
however i do think that if europe wants
some kind of
democratic change in belarus they have
to take in the account the position of
russia
and talk to russia as well yeah
and when we talk about the significance
of russia and the significance of
vladimir putin it has been suggested
that what we're actually experiencing
is another exchange of fire in a in a
long
slowly escalating proxy war between
uh between minsk on one side
and and moscow on one side and uh and
the european union on the other side is
that
too far-fetched well it's a good
question i mean
uh there is an interesting point of view
that uh
this particular act of lokashenko the
landing of the rhinoplane is his way
of burning the bridges with the european
union and thus
kind of causing up to putin and showing
that you really are
my last supporter i really have to
depend on you 100
right now um on the other hand it is
well known that putin is not
a fan of lukashinka personally their
personal relationship is not great
lukashenko also doesn't really like
putin that much and you could even see
it in the way that the situation in
belarus was initially covered
by the russian state media like russia
today when it all just started
now it's very prolokashenko but at the
beginning they were even somehow
sympathetic for the protesters
the first few days it quickly changed
however
it is however what we can also look at
is the treatment of the russian citizen
lukashenko's girlfriend
sophia zapaga who is detained in belarus
and we do not really see
many attempts of the russian politicians
to try to free her
marie zaharova the spokesperson of the
russian foreign
ministry said that the russian council
in minsk has talked to her but that was
all she said they didn't say oh we're
working hard to free her she's innocent
none of that so there must have been
some kind of coordination between minsk
and moscow in this particular
case we will probably never know the
extent of it
okay let's go back to robon protacovich
and find out what his
young political career tells us about
the current generation
of protesters and the mood in belarus
itself
solidarity with roman portazevich the 26
year old co-founded the telegram channel
nexter
where he reported on demonstrations
arrests and violence in belarus
he is now living in exile in lithuania
back in his homeland he was wanted on
charges including inciting protests
against lukashenko
last sunday a ryan airplane traveling
between two eu countries was forced to
land at the airport in minsk by a
belarussian military jet
under the pretext of a bomb scare
and his girlfriend were arrested
immediately
three other passengers who boarded the
plane in athens did not arrive at their
destination in vilnius lithuania
they were according to ryanair ceo
michael o'leary
bella russian secret service kgb agents
a video of puertocevic has since been
released in it he states that he is
being treated fairly by the authorities
viewers however believe it was obtained
by force
is the protozervich affair likely to
explode
olga how explosive is the situation
surrounding roman protozoa
well it's quite frightening i mean we
still have death penalty in belarus
versus the only european country where
death penalty is still in practice and
practice
literally every year and he
could face up to 15 years but
we never know how the situation develops
i mean in the worst case i
really hope it doesn't happen but this
danger is still there being talked about
is a very genuine
shocking possibility yes but once again
he's i mean
this death penalty cases we see it every
year in belarus and it's it's really
about the
the nature of the autocratic state and
it was never abolished in belarus that's
the problem and
he's actually seen officially seen as a
terrorist in belarus and it's
something really different just to be an
oppositional leader or human rights
defender or
uh to be percepted as a terrorist it's
an interesting mixture journalist
blogger opposition journalist
activist if you so well dissident he's
been described how much does he
does he represent his generation because
he's still a very young man he's 26
years old
oh well yes he is young but
i mean the role that not he personally i
mean he
there was a group of people who were uh
in charge of this telegram channel
it was crucial for organizing uh the
produce and valerie's last year it was
not the reason for the progress but
they managed through telegram channels
through social media to organize people
to mobilize them
and we saw hundreds of thousands people
on the street so it was
it's not about his personalities it was
real political danger for
kashanka back then
but when you mention his personality
there is i you know i read constantly
that there is a very
personal element to the animosity
between the blogger
and the president well i don't know that
i can only think that it could be true i
mean luka shank is a person who who
never forgives his fines
and he is a very revenge oriented person
of course this
we cannot exclude this psychological
factor but once again
it was a real political danger back then
so it's not only about some
personalities
it's about organizing a revolution in
batteries so one one of the organizers
of protests
physical or physically organizing the
produce the people were
ready to protest they had this protest
mood but
they managed to do it through social
media and i think
it's of course it's also interesting for
security forces just to get
this information out of him how it
really happened why
why it was that successful i think they
have the feeling
the state i think the belarusian state
has not
understood what actually happened they
still want to understand what was it
what was it last year these protests
unprecedented protests that lasted half
a year
they still want to know what is behind
it and it's not about nieto protest it's
about
people it's about the change political
reality in belarus but they still
have this hope if they close everybody
in prison or make them leave their
country
the situation will come back but it will
not come back alexandra how are people
peter yeah
yeah maybe i can just jump in if you
allow me
because i think that's um it could also
be that this incident
uh it's not only about the blogger uh
it's also about sending a message to the
west that lokashenko is apparently
thinking he can act with
with impunity he can do whatever he
wants to without
fearing any major consequences and
this also could be a strong message to
all
other you know opposition figures
journalists uh civil society members
look no one uh can protect you i can get
you
and this is of course a a very
very dangerous development but that
could be also um
part of his thinking behind what
happened uh in minsk
sorry what's your what's your response
to this uh this debate about whether the
you know the personality of the
of protozoa is important whether or
whether he's part of a generation
is it the individual or is it the is it
the the
the people surrounding him and people
working with him as well
i think it's more of the telegram
channel nectar because i can say it's a
journalist
they you cannot call them proper
journalists they are
biased they use uh even the figures of
what you can say
hate speech i'm sure olga can enlighten
us more on this later but
they use very derogatory phrases so for
example
they use the term lucashist which is a
a mixture of two words fascist fascist
and lukashenko
so they are openly calling belarusian
police um
sadists like they are very kind of
spreading this very particular
very aggressive protest mood on their
telegram channel
however they were very good at reporting
protests they had
a video feed several videos uploaded
every day
showing protests happening in very
different cities around belarus
so they were of course they were not why
the protests happened but they were an
important
part of the protest movement they were a
way for people to feel connected
uh and they played a very important role
in that regard and i think that is why
lokashenko hates berta savage so much
olga what can you add to that for us
i do completely agree i mean i also
agree with the hate speech
we see it actually in both levels on
this on the level state media but also
on the level of telegram channels it's
it's really well the belarusian society
is now
really deeply divided and it's not that
good but think about
perspectives for the time after
lukashenko if
we could imagine any kind of
reconciliation in society it makes it
really really hard
but if you allow me to come back just to
change the to come back to the topic of
the european reaction because i would
like to react to
this um comment uh from from the
colleague in brussels
um that with this air ban for belarusian
airlines
uh the eu intends to punish um
the belarusian regime which is
understandable for me but we
as i've said in this statement at the
beginning i mean
the question i'm asking myself the whole
time i mean what happens
with the whole bill of russia with all
the belarusians that are kind of
unfortunately and i'm sure unintendedly
from the eu but still kind of locked
within their own country where
such unprecedented level of um
repression still happening i mean we
know that
um since the end of 2020 belarusians
have problems
crossing the land border of belarus
because of the official of covet
regulations but we know that
most probably the reasons are political
so
air flights has been the only way for
those who wanted
to leave the country out of political
reasons till now
now if it really happens that belarusian
airlines
cannot enter the european union what
happens with the people i mean i just
want to ask if
this aspect was some kind of also
discussed on the eu level or you think
it could some kind be
changed within the upcoming months or
is it is it on the agenda alexandra
in brussels so it's not yes it's not
officially on the agenda
but uh um it's fair to say that we can
assume
that that was discussed during
the summit of the eu leaders here in
brussels
because of course they know that the
european union is walking a tight rob
here they want
a rope here they want to punish the
regime they don't want to punish
the people of belarus they want to
support and strengthen the civil society
but i think that the first reaction and
this overflight
ban and then the ban for bellavia to
land at uh
benin bilalia from landing at the
european
airports it was also about safety we
talked about that
and then of course it was also about
sending a strong signal i can imagine
that you know that
they can review those measures after a
while
and of course they understand that it's
also going to affect
normal citizens but we have uh to
mention that they were even
much more extreme measures on the table
that were discussed here in brussels
like uh
cutting of banning all traffic even
including ground uh transit from belarus
to the european union and they um said
no
to to those proposals so that's
always a difficult decision uh how to
you know
punish the government and not to punish
the people and of course you have
to find a solution that all members can
agree on
thank you okay very interesting those
are the proposals what do
what do people in brussels imagine the
impact of those proposals
is likely to be again in the next in the
coming days weeks and months
well they are certainly hoping to
change the regime's behavior
but as we could see in the past um
lukashenko more and less struck off
everything that brussels was doing
and the other sanctions imposed on the
regime but now
they seem to be willing to go even
further to uh to sanction
uh to do impose sanctions against um
you know whole industrial sectors
hoping that that could uh change
lukashenko's behavior and change the
situation
on the ground and the other thing that
they are talking about and
have also implemented
is you know to to provide the civil
society
with chances to to grow to support them
uh they decided to to their they're
going to spend 24 million
a million euros to to to do that so uh
that's also another
um thing that they are willing to do
however
we have to say that their toolbox is is
limited
as long as the russian president
vladimir putin is supporting uh
minsk politically but also um
economically
yeah and at the top of the show olga
said that it is of the essential
importance that we
the eu uh talk directly
to vladimir putin about the future of
belarus what did you have in mind there
uh i don't see that there is some big
meeting of putin
with say joseph burrell or sullivan
however there is an important meeting
between vladimir putin
and joe biden the president of the
united states and geneva
if i am not mistaken middle of june yeah
that could potentially be uh the
moment when they will talk about it and
as far as i remember the u.s state has
actually confirmed that belarus is on
their agenda
so maybe they can talk about something
there
but it is very hard to do any kind of
predictions here putin is
known to act rather unpredictably
another important thing
is that there is a general election uh a
presidential election as well
in russia uh in september the 19th
actually
one week before germany has a general
election putin does not want to show
probably you will not want to show any
weaknesses before that and that's really
soon
september is not not far away um however
we cannot people often
say that oh putin would like to annex
belarus and completely merge russian
belarus
because this will give him the same
boosted rating as he did with crimea in
2014. that's not true
there is no second crimea crimea did
have a certain effect on putin's rating
he really did go through the roof the
moment it was annexed it
is deflated now again but belarus isn't
some country that russians want to see
integrated
into russia it's crimea was such an
issue this was the only existing one
this is now gone so it is really hard to
predict what
putin is welcome is ready to put in the
bargaining table with biden
olga do you have any reason to be
immediately optimistic about the
situation
just to round up the show today that
might help
some oppositional forces in the end if
we see the sanctions maybe they will
have
more weight in europe than they used to
be before due to this
due to this rhino story but
i don't know really i it's really
everything is happening there is
okay we'll have to leave it there we've
been talking about the latest crisis in
belarus so thank you very much for
joining us i hope we've
provided you with plenty of food for
thought bye-bye
[Music]
[Music]
you